hallo mein name ist hier kommen heute zu
einem neuen video abhängig mitbekommen
fit bin der immer noch vor allem hype
falls dem nicht was die teile können die
können das hier ja
die können sich drehen alle natürlich in
die kamera guckt mal dass diese nicht
richtig langsam drehen würde aber
eigentlich ist er so mega schnell ein
paar sekunden später
das tue ich mit meinem leben die drehen
sicherheit aufgrund der unzähligen
kugellager relativ lang oder irgendwann
werden die halt so langsam und dann
irgendwann komplett aus zu drehen und
ich habe mir halt gedacht okay ich
bestelle mir zwar mal so ein ding
deswegen wird das dürfte gerade erst
dreht sich einfach immer noch alter aber
dann habe ich mich in die weiten des
internets begeben und mir gedacht hey
was ist wenn jemand kein geld hat
irgendwie 10 euro für kinder ausgegeben
die kadetten tolle beste was wir machen
und wie kann er ein männer spiel spielen
virtual forge spinner von magnolien
schauen wir uns heute drei verschiedene
wittener spiel daran dass wir das war
mein versprechen hier das erste spiel
virtual bittet biergarten vorgelesen
flaschenwärmer training contracting
release
das war alles dass wir konkrete
anscheinend daraus dass wir hier unsere
maus nehmen können und hier hin und her
ziehen können das wird einfach mal bis
zum ende und jetzt sehen wir schon sehr
dünner
[Applaus]
[Musik]
was ist das für eine musik 2000 jahre
später das war's
das ist quasi das komplette spiel wenn
man diese verdammte musik hier aus alles
packt er noch ab also wir haben hier
oben quasi einen balken und wenn wir die
ganze zum ende ziehen dann der trip in
all dem entsprechend relativ schnell und
dreht sich auch schon die ganze zeit ihr
seht ich glaube dass wir sondern ein
stoppzeichen wenn wir darauf klicken
stopp der und wenn ich mir so ein
bisschen hoch hier seht ihr schon der
drehten sich relativ wenig
das spiel bekommt auf einer skala von 1
500 spielpunkten sonne - 40 millionen
der bonus
das macht das spiel auch nicht besser
wenn er das irgendwas an dem ding hier
wenig im hintergrund ändern
wir schauen uns einfach mal die
kommentare unter diesen spielern und
zwar schreiben die leute kredite street
wird dem hause beckham einer bid cool
warum feiert ihr dieses beschissene
spiel die pistolenkugel and luxury and
luxury
allein dem spiel der wittener er so
gedreht wird und dann erst so
immer noch dass so etwas in der kamera
stoppt den jetzt noch so langsam sieht
wie schnell der eigentlich ist
[Musik]
kommt mir alles schreiben das angeblich
volker oppitz platz dafür
es gibt jedoch ganz andere spiele
radiohit bilder entkoppelt es die datei
zu finden hier draufklicken project bei
williams sammy wir kriegen einfach mal
auf
[Musik]
droste regnet machen wir mal relativ
weit auseinander wir machen natürlich
ihr segment der caractere so koller
option machen wir so ein bisschen dies
natürlich auch den titel klarmachen wir
auch von bisschen rosarot und hier das
ganze auf den hell das heißt wir können
jetzt ausbilden drücken und können auch
stoppen drücken
wow
wir schauen uns da mal die kommentare
sind die leute komplett am arsch also
hier haben leute anscheinend
irgendwelche chaoten die kommentare
geschrieben die man jetzt wohl
kommentieren kann dann kann man das
jetzt wird dann gibt man hier einen
kreisliga b
hat nicht so ganz geklappt auch jene mit
auf laut klicken das heißt wir gehen
jetzt den code einklicken die draußen
nehmen
best games ever you know wenn andere
spiel und zwang müssen wir hier den
linken und rechten stick nehmen um das
benennen das halt link neuling aus
gehaltenen stimmrechten bisschen
gedrückt mit denen auf der rechten seite
mit den schnellen lassen
jetzt meinen schaut mal die ganze zeit
in die mitte von den coaches vielleicht
ein bisschen gleich was die optische
illusion oder sonne eine täuschung haben
wird aber ich kann mir das vorstellen
also schaut mal weiter in die mitte von
dem bittet bin keine sorge ich werde
jetzt nicht irgendwie einwänden von
wegen gegen den erschreckend green oder
irgendwie sowas also einfach weiter in
die mitte schauen ich würde sagen machen
das nur fünf sekunden hier 331 jetzt
weggucken
hat überhaupt nichts verändert
das nächste spiel was ich aus wut habe
halt findet die game das ganze aus wir
können einfach mal auf play drücken und
haben jetzt den vettel-finger ich weiß
nicht wie das funktioniert was man da
drücken würden
irgendwas ist ja bewegt haye
wie das funktioniert die unten auf
dieses zeichen sehen hier auch hey das
sind die teile die wir noch freischalten
müssen wenn wir hier draufklicken gar
nichts zig mal wieder auf play und ich
drücke jetzt wirklich gar nicht freuen
also ich hab meine hände hier guck mal
da dreht sich einfach von alleine
wendeten ihr fax
das muss ich hier tun die findet jetzt
eigentlich dass ich wieder meine alten
jahr am start aber das ist natürlich
alles soldaten hier wieder so ein
bisschen aber ich habe einfach nie pop
diese riesige der beerdigung megatrend
er ist immer noch oder wieder hunderte
andere video des weltraums ich weiß
nicht was ich hier machen wo sich nicht
auf play ich das ding da passiert
einfach nicht
denn
oder etwas mit zeichen weil weg ins
lager also ich habe gerade gelesen davon
die maus nehmen soll
um den billa bedienschritte binden
lassen also jetzt niemand
warum funktioniert es nicht oder muss
ich die ganze zeit irgendwie drauf
drücken und den drehen oder irgendwie so
oder geht es hier mit irgendwie geht
honig
brinkmann
ich bin gerade in den app store gegangen
und war in die kategorie charts gratis
und buses auf platz 1 eine app mit dem
namen bittet den finger als männer
ich vertrage ich mal kurz weg widmen um
und die app schauen uns auch noch an
eine ewigkeit später also so sieht die
app aus meine damen und herren ich auf
jeden fall schon mal besser als die
anderen ein bisschen durchdachter mit
soll angeblich die wiederum finden und
dadurch können wir den patienten drehen
wenn ich meine videos gefallen dann
würde ich mich über einen daumen hoch
freuen
sie können dadurch jetzt glaube ich 20
reward punkte kollekten detailliert
wieder so ein bisschen fakt wir haben
immer nur ein paar slide flat für jeden
dings fällt mir auch er findet bis in
die fingerspitzen spieler gestoppt wir
haben 19
die kollekten können und können quasi
jetzt einmal dann haben wir warten noch
mal soweit nochmals bei noch einmal
drehen und noch einmal drehen 41 wenn
leute allen daumen hoch da lassen
probiert es einfach noch mal wenn ich
mir immer sehr viel zeit hatte also so
einmal dann so einmal dann machen wir
nochmal so einmal und noch einmal und
einnahmen noch übrig nämlich ihr den
letzten aber das wird nicht so gut seien
diesmal diesmal haben wir 33 stücken
oder wir müssten anscheinend wirklich
das ganze relativ gut ab hatten also
einmal so nochmal so nochmal so noch mal
so und noch mal so hörte was werden
meine damen und herren aber nebel sind
bei 80 das zweite was für welche
liesemann die klicken wieder auf collect
haben diesmal auch was das denn
wenn ihr zusatzteile kaufen gibt euch
das mal vier kranke geschwindigkeit
jetzt weiter dass wir dort von neuer
high score freunde scharf an
upgraded
die können das will reflection verlangen
dann haben wir den märkten wie dem
dating ein bisschen hoch wie hat man
nicht mehr und wir können auch leben
die profis ihnen einmal der war richtig
schütten noch einmal der relativ gut
noch einmal der war auch relativ guten
noch einmal der auch ganz in ordnung und
noch einmal freunde da wir können
diesmal wirklich neuen heizung sind bei
55 56 56 stück weiter nukem ich würd
sagen wir level nicht wieder mal so ein
bisschen hoch erster bin nicht immer ein
bisschen beschissen weil man sicher noch
ein bisschen an schwung geben muss und
weiter noch keinen habe ich und dann
kommen wir jetzt zum letzten hier könnte
wieder neue high score werden wir sind
bei 55 56 57 58 diesmal upgraden dietmar
redle turner und machen noch einen
letzten zwei also der erste war diesmal
sogar einigermaßen vernünftig der zweite
geht auch klar der dritte geht auch
wieder klar machen wir den vierten und
meine damen jetzt den fünften noch mal
dass wir wieder neue highs 55 56 58 59
kein recht sich aber wir haben 59 9
highscore können hier unter dem
aufleveln haben doch mal hier den neuen
acht kaum leute
wir probieren den nochmal ein und die
nummer hat zwei und die nummer drei und
die nummer 4 und den letzten nummer fünf
das heißt wir sind bei 6 168 9 und 16
uhr endlich gefallen habe ich mich sehr
über den daumen hoch für mich war es
mika unterhaltsam einfach verschiedene
widmen als findet jetzt ein smiley
eingeblendet wenn ihr darauf könnt ihr
meinen kanal kopftuch abonnieren
verpasst dadurch keine videos mehr also
mir gefällt auch meinen shop
eingeblendet in dem wie gesagt am
perfekten unter anderem dieses feature
der launischen werden und hier unten ist
ein anderes video verlinkt und wenn ihr
jetzt noch dran seid dann kommentiert
mal für spinner